a moment of relief after days of
uncertainty migrants aboard the Alex
rescue ship step onto land rescuers say
the conditions on the boat had grown
horrific including no functioning
toilets and the lack of water
that's why on Saturday the ship's
operators radioed in to port to say they
would defy Italy's orders not to dock
there we are in emergency conditions
that force us to go to the nearest port
because we're out of our food and water
supplies we are overcrowded with several
cases of physical pain caused
principally by the hot weather
the decision to dock violated orders
from Italian interior minister Matteo
salvini he has banned unauthorized
rescue boats from entering Italy's ports
and salvini has hit back at foreign
officials including from Germany who
have criticized the move dear German
government I am NOT reopening Italian
ports especially if you ask me to if
there's a German ship then you take care
of it or we'll put the migrants on a bus
to the German embassy same goes for the
French the Dutch and anyone who thinks
they can do what they want in Italy and
that German ship Matteo salvini was
referring to as the Alan Kurdi it's run
by CI a German aid organisation it also
tried to dock in Italy over the weekend
but was denied entry it's now sailing
with more than 60 rescued migrants on
board for ports and Malta instead for
more let's bring in DW correspondent Amy
NASA fees and land producer following
the story for us
i'm ian italian authorities certainly
didn't want these people on their shore
so how were they received
well a coordinator for the Metta Tonia
that's the NGO that's responsible for
that ship that came into port against
Italy's wishes they told me it was sheer
torture what the people on board had to
go through after spending almost two
days out at sea they were forced to
spend another eight hours in port
waiting almost without explanation as
the authorities decided what to do with
them now after they came off that boat
eight hours after they had come in it
was fairly standard procedure from there
they were taken to the immigration
center like a lot of migrants who
arrived on this island but they were
also greeted by a welcoming committee
some activists had come out with a sign
saying welcome to Lambos lampa deucey as
well there were people who were jeering
at them telling them to go home ami and
the interior minister said that the
vessels crew would be placed under
investigation for abetting illegal
immigration have we gotten any reaction
from the crew yet well a spokesperson
for the NGO speaking for the crew said
and the captain said that they remain
firmly behind their decision to come
into port they said it was their
humanitarian duty they were obeying
international maritime law to come into
the closest port they said they could
not last out an ocean any longer could
not make the trip to Malta which had
originally welcomed them so they say
that there was no criminal activity of
course matteo salvini as we heard is
says that it was a political act just to
go out and pick up migrants and then
come to Lampa duza knowing full well
that they would have to force their way
in now he's all of this deepening rifts
in Europe's migration policy
well that depends on who you ask
of course on the island of Lampedusa if
you can take that for an example it's
very much polarized you have the one
side who sees the lives of those rescued
out at sea as the most important thing
here and says politics needs to be
resolved once people come to land and
then you have the other people who see
it as NGOs going out and picking up
people from North Africa and bringing
them to Europe's Shores so if you take
that as an example for all of Europe and
certainly things are becoming more
polarized ami and Asif in land producer
for us thank you very much